well bless their hearts all these lovely
people and like our program so much they
want our signatures on stuff that
they've owned for many years in some
cases which is sweet what is some of the
most memorable things you've signed over
the years Oh
clothing bodies chamber pots you name it
anything I've signed it what was the
appeal for you of being part of
something like Doctor Who when you took
on your time in the TARDIS well it's a
job I'm an actor and over 40 years of
being an actor I've had a lot of jobs
this is one which is a cult had some
experience of that before when I did the
brothers in the 70s which was very
popular it's a it's a nice thing to be
able to do a job that people care about
thirty years later in my case which is
thirty years since I played doctor and
here you are in this strange building
here full of people who still want to
celebrate that we're very lucky have you
stayed watching the series over the
years
yes intermittently when I have not been
busy doing other things I have been
watching it I missed the last season
because I was working but yeah you keep
an eye on the program and in particular
the last doctor's seen to turn into new
doctor what do you think about Peter
Capaldi what do you think he will bring
to the park every single doctor has been
brilliant as far as I can see I think
Matt Smith has been brilliant and I have
no doubt that Peter Capaldi who was an
actor actor I've been watching for many
years and admiring is going to be
equally brilliant you think it's nicer
to a fan of the show as well as taking
on that role because he's a massive fan
of Doctor Who - I mean by fan I'm sure
Peter Capaldi's never been to a
convention he might have done but he
says he's always enjoyed watching the
show and I enjoyed watching the show
before I was in it I don't think you
need to be a fan of the program to be in
it but it helps to get immersed it more
quickly if you're aware of what it is
you're you're joining because it's quite
a formidable machine
rolling relentlessly forward to the
hundred years it will doubtless reach
because it don't sing at all when you
step into that role no no I was offered
it and I thought yes I'd like to do that
perhaps I should have been daunted but
I'm I wasn't that I was I was uplifted
really when you said it's gonna probably
roll on 600 years of course or in the
50th year at the moment have you seen
the latest mini episode that was
released this week the night of the
doctor yes I've seen Paul being
brilliant in his seven minutes prequel
to what's coming up very very good I
thought it was beautifully done look at
him he's such a good actor so I enjoyed
that enormous Lee and he's had his
regeneration at last which is good so
I'm the only person who hasn't
regenerated because I wasn't present for
my regeneration so would you like to see
it some point you Stefan binds the
doctor has to see that regeneration to
close that Booker well they pretended to
do it
they had Sylvester in a blond wig
pretending with me but he doesn't count
really so he's not really the doctor
because I wasn't there so I am still the
doctor they're all they're all imposters
Peter Capaldi's impostor Matt Smith
David Tennant they are a new line of
doctors that started with Sylvester so
the first season series finished at
number 6 then they start again at number
1 with Sylvester pretending to be me so
he was the first of Part two
the second division
and with pause regeneration now does
this mean were accurate of 13th or final
doctor now not the 12 he's a time
traveler he can do what he likes you can
travel back and change the rules I don't
think anyone's going to be too worried
about the twelve regenerations I think
the master it has been established
already had extra generations so if he
can do it I'm sure the doctor can now
what would you look forward to seeing in
the 50th anniversary special do you
think what do I think would be in it
Oh from what the trailer shows me a lot
of explosions which I love I love a lot
of explosions they can do all that so
brilliantly now so I'm looking forward
to something that'll blow the screen
apart would you like to join the doctor
at some point in the future you thinking
the opportunity came up well there's a
very good reason why that is not
necessarily possible and all you have to
do is do that so I think it very
unlikely well that I could play another
part in it I could be a Silla Dean
perhaps do you like that flatulent
monster yes of course I can do
flatulence
we'd absolutely love to see you again a
doctor who in any role as long as you're
flatulent but I'll do it
you